michelle if an actor gets a part whether
it's a leading role or just a few lines
in a play how much time should they
devote to that role outside of
rehearsals
how much should they really own that and
just work on it depends what the role is
really depends what it is and how
challenging
it is for them sometimes
you can overwork something and then it
robs you of spontaneity
and sometimes you need to feel that the
confidence you need to give yourself you
know more more rehearsal so it really it
depends it varies
with every person in every project i
would say
david and i saw a young man one time at
the corner in north hollywood just
you could see he was just owning this
role and he was totally oblivious and he
was walking down lancashire and just
reciting things would you recommend that
for some if that's what you need to do
and that's what he needed to do for
himself absolutely
you know again it goes back to knowing
yourself
really well as an actor and trusting
that you have to do what you have to do
sometimes
if you're shooting a very difficult
scene you can't be social on set you
have to create a bubble around you
and you have to stay to yourself of
course it's a little hard you know if
you're a new actor and
you know it all depends how you do it
but i think that the most important
thing is what's on the screen so
whatever it takes to make that
performance happens
and you know that you have to deliver
that so you have to know what you have
to do in order to to get there
you